if the media is a source of inaccuracies
and
even lies
then how do we find the truth
i don't regard the media as a source of
as a
source of inaccuracies and lies
they do exist
but by and large
media reporting is
reasonably accurate
uh reporters
the journalists themselves does in the
past do
courageous
honest work
i've
written about this for 50 years my
opinion hasn't changed
but they do
pick certain things and not other things
there's selection
there's framing
there's ways of presenting things
uh
all of that
forms a kind of
propaganda system which you have to work
your way through
but it's
rarely a matter of straight outright
lying
so there's a difference between
propaganda and lying of course a
propaganda system
shapes and limits
the material that's presented
it may tell the truth within that
framework
so let me give you a concrete example
which i
wrote about extensively
i have a book called
manufacturing consent jointly with
edward herman
it's about the
his term which i had accepted the
propaganda model of the media
about a large part of the book is
defense of the media
defense of the media against
harsh attacks
by freedom house
several volumes they published attacking
the media
charging that the media were so
adversarial and dishonest that they lost
the war in vietnam
well i took the trouble of reading
through the two volumes
one volume is charges the next volume is
evidence
turns out that all of the evidence is
lies
they had no evidence
they were just lying the media in fact
were doing the journalists were doing an
honest
courageous work
but
within a certain framework
a framework of assuming that
the american cause was
basically just basically honorable
making mistakes
doing bad things
but all
but the idea of questioning
that the united states was engaged in a
major
war crime
that's off the record
so unfortunately there was this crime
and that crime which
harmed their effort to do good and so on
well that's not lying it's propaganda
so how do we find the truth
how do we find the truth
that's what you have a brain for
it's not deep
it's quite shallow
it's not it's not quantum physics
put a little effort into it
think about
uh look for other sources
think a little about history
look at the documentary record
it all pretty well falls together and
you can get a reasonable
understanding of what's happening
you